其实我们这一辈子很少有这样的机会能做到一个月挣8万块钱的这个事儿，
所以当我们一旦一个月能挣8万块钱的时候，
我们确实会有这样的心理的冲动，
想要去向其他人证明我现在一个月能挣8万块钱了，
甚至想要去向父母、
兄弟、
闺蜜、
同学、
老师、
朋友去展示我现在一个月挣8万块钱了，
这是属于正常的心理冲动，
但是后面才是重点啊。
但是你听好了，
每当你有这种心理冲动和心理诉求的时候，
你扇自己的耳巴子，
我今年是24岁，
我男朋友是23岁，
现在我们已经订婚了，
我现在是今年刚毕业，
他是明年要毕业大学，
目前的话，
我们的婚房是正在装修，
有两辆车，
一辆是全款是他妈妈买我名下，
还有一辆是他妈妈最近买的，
在男朋友名下，
是贷款，
我们现在是一起做生意，
因为我已经毕业了嘛，
男朋友现在是开户实习，
因为在家，
目前我是在他家，
可我我们现在月收入是差的，
是8万左右吧，
要是好吃几个，
以前一直是我在管，
今年我们4月份就要结婚了，
但是说实话我心里已经害怕，
所以我想问问你几个问题呢，
不姐，
第一个我妈妈说现在可以备虐男方各个条。
既都很好，
他就很满意嘛，
所以呢，
就是对背因孕他不是太担心，
但是我觉得是不是会有一点草率了，
我其实也是很喜欢小孩，
经济条件的话，
目前来说我觉得也是够的，
但是总觉得刚结婚就备虐，
是不是有点突然，
你手上有多少存款呀？
我手上现在是40个，
因为一个月就能挣8万块钱，
我感觉我不知道你做的这个业务是一个风口还是可持续的，
如果说做的这个业务是一个风口的话，
趁着年轻还是多挣钱吧，
我也是这样，
亲爱的的，
如果这个生意主要是由你来注册个体户，
由你来收款，
由你来经营的话，
那么我们第一要请专业的财务的人员，
要注意税务的风险，
要进行税务的这样一个规划，
第二的话就坚持以你为主，
因为他现在还在大学，
还没毕业嘛，
对不对，
坚持以你为主，
自己掌握财政大权，
再有一个的话，
如果做这个事情，
他不是那种说一眼能望到头，
以后往后余生的10年20年，
每个月都能挣8万块钱的话，
那我就趁着现在能挣8万块钱的时候，
我抓紧时间挣钱才是王道，
因为你年龄小，
你才二十几岁，
你手上有40万的存款和400万的存款，
完全是不同的人生，
不同的体验，
也是不同的安全感。
社慧也是这样觉得的，
而且人家男方还没有毕业，
男方毕业了之后在哪工作还不一定，
跟你在一起做生意，
两个人脾气能不能合得来还不一定，
这些都要等到时候真正毕业了，
走入社会了，
一起去参与社会竞争了，
大家对钱的态度怎么怎么样了，
再看不着急啊。
那卢之姐建议我，
不是刚结婚就开始备孕是吧？
我不建议我其实我也是这样觉得的，
我们这里有点迷信了，
他们都说么混小宝宝很好啊，
谣言都不太好，
我就挺焦虑的，
当你一个月能挣8万块钱的时候，
千万不要再听那些没有见过一个月8万块钱的人的这些意见，
明白吗？
这些还有第二个问题是，
我感觉我男朋友各方面都很好，
他还是独生子，
有时候我这方面是感觉他对他的家庭有点过度付出了，
就比如前段时间我会买车嘛，
为啥这家不是太便宜，
他心疼他妈妈，
就说贷款是他来还，
这件事就是他还可以，
但是他没有跟我提前商量，
我当时特别生气，
我们还大吵一架，
因为我攒钱的目标是以后让我们的小孩儿过得更舒服一点，
而且我感觉并没有亏待于他们家，
因为我刚开始起步的时候，
是他妈妈给我投资什么的都是他妈妈，
所以我很感激，
而且我现在欠他妈是。
20个吧，
鬼的还心了，
所以我感觉在付出还心里不太舒服，
如果你想跟这家人好好的生活下去的话，
需要调整你的心态，
因为他是独生子了，
他对家庭的付出难免的，
你如果说你想跟他好好的相处的话，
这是需要我们去克服的一个心理的魔障，
她是独生子，
她对原生家庭的付出是难免的，
对面白真的要有感恩之心，
要记得我来时的路，
如果不是婆婆投资，
如果不是婆婆帮衬我的话，
我未必现在一个月能挣8万块钱，
某种程度上，
婆婆是我的生命当中的贵人，
很多东西不是说你还了20万这个账就了了的，
从我的内心来说的话，
我是这么看待问题的，
你明白我理姐，
那确实这个是我想的一点过了，
如果说分手的话，
我还是真舍不得，
因为那时候我就很生气，
他没有跟我商量吧，
想分手，
但是我后来想想，
我还是真舍不得，
因为我刚毕业就有了现在的收入，
离不开他家的支持，
而且她爸妈一直对我很好，
那时候她妈妈投资我的时候，
我男朋友还不在家，
我感觉我的男朋友偶尔有点小毛病，
可能是独生子的缘故，
有时候感觉他有一点自私，
我也经常因为这些事跟他吵架，
就比如我跟他交流的时候，
他有时候不理我，
还有我感觉他对别人态度跟对我的态度不一样，
但是我生过气之后又自己。
去反思了，
我现在的生活够好了，
但是还是觉得有点不舒服，
我不知道以后该怎么跟他相处，
现在因为他还没毕业嘛，
他以后还面临找工作的事情嘛，
我觉得现在做好避孕措施，
就一门心挣钱，
真的，
姐妹哦，
一个月能挣8万块钱的事情，
现在你其他的什么都不要给我去想，
不要想烂事儿，
不要想乱七八糟，
其他的什么人际关系都不要管，
就可以一门心思的去挣钱，
守好你的钱房，
诈骗，
防什么情感陷阱，
就有一门心思的去挣到钱，
真的，
你要相信龙飞姐，
你现在手上只有40万的存款，
等你手上有200万、
300万、
400万的存款的时候，
你整个人的想法会发生翻天覆地的变化，
一门心思的去赚钱啊，
明白浪费钱，
那我是不是现在是主要是就是挣钱，
你少跟他吵架，
我现在是感觉只要把他哄开心，
其他的都省事了，
是不是这样？
Oh no,
把我自己哄开心，
其他的才能一顺百顺，
我自己挣到钱了我开心，
我自己事业有发展了我开心，
我自己的工作上有成就了我开心，
不是说把他哄高兴了，
我怎么怎么样，
不把我自己哄开心，
那我该怎么克服自己呀？
因为我平时看见，
我知道我是占有欲太强了，
他跟别人说话和我的态度不一样，
我就很难受。
我不知道该怎么办，
这么说吧，
还是那句话，
你现在手上只有40万的存款，
等你的手上有400万的存款的时候，
就应该是他紧张你了，
怕你跟别人说话了。
明白了，
飞仙，
还有第三个问题是我妈妈也跟着我们做这个生意了，
其实一开始我不是特别同意的，
因为我的原生家庭不是太好，
小时候我爸妈经常吵架，
给我留下了很大阴影，
本来我是计划着长大后离他们远一点，
但是我男朋友的妈妈觉得等我们以后生了小孩，
我妈妈可以帮我们带，
所以就拉着我妈妈一起做了。
姑娘啊，
听好了，
如果你觉得你和你妈妈之间没有太深的感情的话，
千万不要说拉到一起来做这个买卖，
做这个生意，
千万不要让你的妈妈去干预你和你男朋友之间的关系，
千万不要让你的妈妈去干预你和你婆婆之间的关系，
千万不要还是那句话，
姑娘，
你真的是格局打开一点，
当你有了400万存款的时候，
你要谁给你带孩子，
我自己花钱请人带孩子，
什么都听你的故香吗？
是的，
我也是这样想的，
但是现在在一起做生意了，
我之前我很反对，
现在我妈妈是要来我男朋友这边做生意嘛，
他没有吃，
我妈要给我准备嫁装嘛，
但是他准备不出来，
我是想的是我自己准备，
就是说是他的名义，
是这样的，
姑娘啊，
你不要告诉任何人，
你一个月能挣8万。
块钱，
任何人问你的时候，
你都抹个零，
就说挣你8000块钱，
并不要跟任何人说啊，
并不是所有的业务关系，
并不是所有的客户关系，
所有的上下游关系都要去告诉别人的，
你给我悄悄的挣钱，
悄悄的存钱啊，
好，
谢谢龙飞奇，
我也看评论区的，
说实话，
我确实是现在刚毕业，
不是太成熟，
我跟你讲一下，
姑娘啊，
如果说我们这样的女孩子之前家庭条件并不是特别富裕，
并不是那种什么资产几千万呀，
上亿的这样一个家庭的话，
其实我们这一辈子很少有这样的机会能做到一个月挣8万块钱的这个事儿，
所以当我们一旦一个月能挣8万块钱的时候，
我们确实会有这样的心理的冲动，
想要去向其他人证明我现在一个月能挣8万块钱了，
甚至想要去向父母、
兄弟、
闺蜜、
同学、
老师、
朋友去展示我现在一个月挣8万块钱了，
这是属于正常的心理冲动，
这属于正常的现象，
正常的心理诉求，
但是后面才是重点啊，
但是你听好了，
每当你有这种心理冲动和心理诉求的时候，
你删自己的耳巴子，
你听懂飞姐的，
每当你想向任何人去证明你一个月能挣8万块钱，
向任何人去展示一下我现在的经济实力的时候，
你就扇自己耳子，
这龙飞姐教你的，
你就悄悄的挣钱，
悄悄的攒。
不要让别人觉得你一下子现在啊飞黄腾达了，
一下子现在就是跟别人不是一个阶级了，
以后出去，
比如说跟朋友们出去吃饭啊什么的，
不要想着请大家去高档的场所去吃饭，
不要想着KTV两三千块钱的这个消费我一个人结账算了，
不千万不要。
龙菲姐现在教你的这些内容都是躲灾躲祸的内容，
都是保平安的内容，
包括亲爹亲妈亲兄弟，
嫡长闺蜜，
都不要说悄悄的发财好不好，
那咱俩就聊到这儿了，
我告诉你们原因是什么好不好？
原因是你是一个女孩儿，
你知道吗？
你是一个女孩儿，
可能在这个整体的社会框架下，
在你的家人看来的话，
你挣的钱就该是全家的，
在婆婆公公眼里看来的话，
你挣的钱就该是我儿子的，
在很多其他的恶意的人看来的话，
就是凭什么你挣这么多钱，
你算老几？
就因为你是一个女孩儿，
你突然一下子一个月能挣8万块钱的话，
谁都盯着你，
至亲血脉盯着你，
老公公公婆婆盯着你，
谁都盯着你，
包括那些曾经比你漂亮，
比你有魅力，
比你成绩好的同学朋友闺蜜都盯着你，
凭什么你挣这么多钱？
记得点赞关注哦。